ISLAM SPREAD FIVE TIMES more than
Christianity in the 50 years. Which war
took place in this 50 years which forced
non-Muslims to become Muslims?
And we find in the media there is
bombardment against the rights of women.
The one point that media attacks Islam
before 911 mainly on the rights of
women. Now they continue it has become
on the second level goes from fifth,
6th, 7th onwards.
Do you know out of those people
accepting Islam 23 are not are women.
Out of those Americans accepting Islam,
twothird are women. Out of those
European European who are accepting
Islam, two3 are women. So if Islam is
subjugating the women, why are the
American women accepting Islam? Why are
the European women accepting Islam?
Because Islam gives them protection.
Islam gives them peace, gives them
honor, gives them dignity.
So the thing that is conquering the
heart is the sword of peace,
sword of intellect.
I would like to end this answer, the
allegation number four, misconception
number four, by a quotation of George
Pier, Adam Pearson. Adam Pearson says
that people who worry that nuclear
weaponry one day will fall in the hands
of the Arabs fail to realize
the Islamic bomb the bomb of peace I'm
saying number has already been dropped
it fell the day prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him was born
though Adam Pearson wrote it as a
negative comment
I am using it as a positive comment.
Adam Pearson wrote it as a sarcasm
that people who worry that one day
nuclear weaponry will fall in the hands
of the Arab. They fail to realize that
the Islamic bomb mean the bomb of
terrorism has already been dropped the
day Prophet Muhammad was born. So I
agree with him.
I agree with him but in the right
context
that people who worry that nuclear
weaponry will fall in the hands of the
Arab they fail to realize the Islamic
bomb the bomb of peace
has already been dropped when you have
the bomb of peace you don't require
nuclear weapon
so I'm giving the right context of Adam
Pearson
people who worry that nuclear weapon
will one day fall in hands of the Arabs
they fail to realize that the Islamic
Big bomb. The bomb of peace has already
been dropped the day prophet Muhammad
was born peace be upon him. And Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam is more
powerful than all your nuclear weapon
put together. He is alone sufficient.
One man in the full world is suffer is
sufficient to conquer the hearts. He's
sufficient to conquer the hearts of the
Americans, the European. However much
you try with your media, this man,
Prophet Muhammad, peace be upon him
alone, the last AND FINAL MESSENGER OF
ALLAH is sufficient
for the whole non-Muslim world alone.
He has Allah's help. And the power of
Allah is more superior than all your
nuclear weapon, atom bomb or bomb put
together. They fail to realize and even
Adam Pearson fails to realize. If you'd
have realized, you'd have accepted
Islam.
The fifth
most common question asked by non-Muslim
is
why does Islam allow a Muslim man to
have more than one wife
or why does Islam allow polygamy?
First let us understand what is the
meaning of the word polygamy.
Polygamy means a person having more than
one spouse. Polygamy is of two types.
Polyandri when a man has more than one
wife.
Polyandri where a woman has more than
one husband. And polygeni when a man has
more than one wife.